une journée historique tels sont les
réactions ou irlandais par référendum
les électeurs permettent l'élargissement
de l'union à dix nouveaux pays journée
de deuil en australie tout un continent
qui pleure ses victimes après l'attentât
de bali minute de silence prières dans
les églises ou recueillement sur la
plage un nouvel examen du permis de
conduire se remplace le 4 novembre
prochain nettement plus dur l'épreuve de
conduite comportera des questions
notamment techniques avec l'idée
d'augmenter le nombre de recalés par
souci de sécurité
gérard jugnot dans un état critique sur
la scène du théâtre fontaine une pièce
drôle caustique émouvante et en costumes
gérard jugnot
il joue le critique littéraire
sainte-beuve fois amoureux de la femme
de victor hugo ou goût dont il enviait
le tas dans jal et gérard jugnot et
neutralité
madame monsieur bonsoir toutes les
chaînes américaines ne parle plus que de
ça ils la psychose gagne les environs de
washington
le tueur en série aurait pu faire hier
soir une nouvelle victime le scénario
est identique
l'homme a été blessé d'une seule balle
sur le parking d'un restaurant
il est entre la vie et la mort mais pour
la première fois le forcené hal gill
loin de la capitale à quelque 150
kilomètres ce qui ajoutait la quiétude
des habitants de washington et des états
voisins etienne leenhardt
méticuleusement des dizaines de
policiers tenté ce matin de mettre la
main sur un indice un détail qui leur
permettrait enfin de suivre une piste
crédible les menant au tueur
cette fois le meurtrier a frappé à plus
de 150 km au sud de washington sur le
parking de ce restaurant
la victime sortait de l'établissement en
compagnie de son épouse hier soir un
seul coup de feu
touché au ventre l'homme âgé de 37 ans
est fondée se trouve aujourd'hui encore
entre la vie et la mort les autorités
attendent la confirmation que le sniper
a frappé une fois de plus rien
d'officiel pour l'instant confirmé ce
shérif il ya trois quarts d'heure mais
la probabilité est grande
le camion de livraison repéré par des
témoins à plusieurs reprises restent
introuvables d'autant que selon les
versions sa taille et sa couleur change
ce qui ne facilite pas le travail des
enquêteurs
la sécurité en ces temps de psychose est
en tout cas en train de devenir un
argument commercial
le gérant de cette station service
attendu un droit pour protéger ses
clients des tirs d'un éventuel meurtrier
c'est un peu surréaliste mais l'idée a
le mérite d'exister il a besoin de faire
le plein j'ai vu dans journal qu'ils
avaient fait ça alors je suis venu ici
que ce cas l'assassinât traité si
l'hypothèse d'un acte du tireur fou est
confirmé ce serait la première fois
qu'il agit pendant le week-end
en l'espace de 17 jours le sniper a tiré
12 fois a tué neuf personnes et en a
blessé grièvement trois journées de
deuil aujourd'hui en australie en
hommage aux victimes de l'attentât de
bali
plus d'une centaine de leurs
compatriotes ont perdu la vie en ce
dimanche jour de prière tous les
australiens se sont recueillis à
l'unisson minute de silence à midi
précise les cloches des églises ont
sonné à la volée les drapeaux sont en
berne dans la ville de perth maintenant
plusieurs milliers de personnes se sont
rassemblées pour une cérémonie à la
chapelle à la mémoire notamment des sept
victimes de l'équipe de football
originaire de la ville sur place nos
envoyés spéciaux philippe rochot et
sylvain siou mhz à la mémoire de dino
dino et l avant centre de l'équipe de
perth
il avait 18 ans et il est mort dans
l'attentât de bali au club de foot
son frère et ses copains ne veulent pas
l'oublier
on nous a dit qu'il était mort sur le
coup il n'a pas souffert
ils étaient 7 de l'équipe aux sarries
club de ben ali
cette mort les autres n'étaient pas
allés danser qu'on ait pu leur tu es une
équipe de foot a profondément choqué les
habitants de perth tout comme les
australiens car ici tout le monde les
connaissait alors ils sont venus par
centaines en pèlerinage au club
pour cette journée d'hommage national la
sylve épicier que c'était des les
avanies c'était la première fois qu'ils
allaient là bas pour les vacances il
était arrivé depuis six heures seulement
quand l'attentât a eu lieu et il était
très populaire ici
ah oui populaire vraiment c'est un super
club
la ville de perth a même organisé pour
eux un hommage à la mesure de la douleur
de ces deux millions d'habitants
car ben ali lui dit si c'était la porte
du paradis
catherine en sait quelque chose elle
venait de quitter le sari club où se
trouvaient les footballeurs quand
l'attentât s'est produit
je suis si triste j'ai tellement de
chance d'être en vie était sur le chemin
du retour est la seule raison pour
laquelle je n'étais pas avec eux c'est
que je ne voulais pas dépenser
je suis hyper content
karine elle est carrément venu signer le
livre de condoléances
par solidarité avec l'équipe de foot de
perth
je les connais tous par le coeur
je viens d'amérique et j'étais horrifiée
par le 11 septembre à la cathédrale de
perth
la messe était dédiée aux sept morts de
l'équipe de foot mais aussi à ses
quelque 115 jeunes de 20 ans qui sont
morts a vécu
un nouvel attentat aux philippines trois
cette fin de semaine une bombe a explosé
à zamboanga ce dimanche près d'une
nécropole catholique au moins 17
blessées à mort l'armée et la police
patrouillaient la recherche d'autres
engins possible c'est fait l'irlande
d'agi oui à l'élargissement de l'union
européenne une victoire indiscutable 62
89 % des électeurs approuvent le traité
de nice 37 11 % ils sont opposés
une véritable volte face seize mois
après le premier référendum où les
irlandais avaient rejeté l'entrée de dix
nouveaux pays dans l'europe à 54 % avec
une abstention record
cette fois ci la campagne électorale à
inciter les électeurs à se mobiliser
c'est un jour historique pour l'irlande
vient de déclarer le premier ministre
et c'est un ouf de soulagement pour
l'union européenne sur place laurent
boussier dominique marocaine
une grande victoire pour les partisans
du oui une grande colère pour les
partisans du non est un ouf de
soulagement des politiciens irlandais
qui dans leur majorité avaient fait
campagne pour cette ratification du
traité de nice je pense que c'est un
signal politique très fort de ne pas de
2,2 peuple irlandais un an après avoir
dit non l'irlande a donc dit oui à un
changement d'opinion expliqué par une
plus grande mobilisation et une plus
forte participation des électeurs élus
noirs du oui qui laisse un goût amer à
ceux qui ont voté non c'est pas juste la
première fois on a voté non au
référendum et ça aurait dû rester la
nuit dernière les résultats des sept
bureaux où l'on votait de manière
électronique laissait déjà entrevoir la
victoire du oui
c'est d'après midi dans le grand salon
de la mairie de dublin chaque nouvelle
annonce confirmait la tendance
à l'arrivée plus de 60 2% de oui et une
irlande qui selon son premier ministre
s'est replacé au coeur de l'ordre
de se sécher chose cette décision montre
avant tout fait notre nation veut
accueillir les bras ouverts les
populations des pays candidats la
satisfaction des politiciens irlandais
n'est rien au regard du soulagement
éprouvé dans toutes les autres capitales
européennes on rire landais et l'europe
était en crise cette crise-là été évité
mais conformément au calendrier de la
commission dix nouveaux pays vont
maintenant rejoindre la communauté
européenne d'ici janvier 2004 en effet
nombreuses réactions de satisfaction dès
les premiers résultats connus les
responsables n'hésitent pas à évoquer à
rendez-vous avec l'histoire avec un
grand h voici en effet l'enjeu de cette
adhésion au traité de nice voilà ce
qu'il a changé selon ce calendrier que
nous détaille christian mary mono la
maison de l'europe des quinze vingts
ouvert ses portes aux dix pays candidats
du côté de la commission européenne
les réactions sont contrastées exprimer
ma satisfaction pour les résultats du
référendum irlandais c'était c'était
incroyable c'était beaucoup mieux que
les prévisions au triomphalisme parce
que derrière ce vote et celui d'avant il
ya des questions et un avertissement les
difficultés vont commencer fin 2002 le
conseil européen des quinze distribuera
les feuilles de route au candidat en
2004 l'europe des 25 prendra forme
problème crucial le financement
l'élargissement passe par des aides
directes aux pays candidats notamment
l'agriculture polonaise désaccord des 15
une priorité construire la nouvelle
maison europe avec pour architecte en
chef valery giscard d'estaing et les 105
membres de la convention européenne
ils ont quelques mois pour proposer une
constitution européenne tâche éminemment
délicate et jacques chirac de jordanie
s'est déclaré particulièrement heureux
du oui irlandais c'est une chance
historique pour l'europe
revenons-en à cet incendie spectaculaire
qui a sévi toute la nuit dans une
décharge illégale de pneus près de
bordeaux des fumées noires qui s'en
dégageait était toxique
une enquête est en cours pour déterminer
les circonstances du sinistre
carline femmes bernard bonne arme
des flammes de 10 à 15 mètres de haut
quarante mille mètres suivent de pneus
ravagé par le feu
l'incendié s'est étendu sur un hectare
de terrain des dizaines de pompiers ont
lutté pendant toute la nuit et des
engins de travaux sont entrés en action
très rapidement pour éviter que le feu
ne se propage
nous avons procédé à ce que l'on appelle
dans les termes techniques la part du
feu c'est à dire nous avons séparé les
parties brûlées des parties non brûlés
laissons les parties brûlées se consumer
parce que c'est extrêmement difficile à
éteindre
et on nous laissons de l'autre côté les
pieds partie non brûlé les mieux qu'ils
ne sont pas compris mais là des soeurs
existe depuis 1995
l'installation est illégal mais aucune
démarche n'a abouti à l'évacuation du
site en 97 sur marquez kool aid avait
créé une association pour en vain hier
soir elle a vu les flammes haïk
centaines de mètres de sa maison
je ne pouvais pas m'expliquer que cela
puisse avoir lieu
surtout sachant que quand même ces
derniers temps il n'y a plus dans les
pneus étant couché plus ou moins ils
sont remplis d'eau c'est pas un mégot ou
une cigarette c'est pas une allumette
qui peut allumer sa accidentelle ou
criminelle
une enquête est en cours mais le maire
de la commune se posent les mêmes
questions
lui aussi se mobilise depuis des années
pour que l'environnement soit respectée
des décharges et de pneus comme celle là
il y en a d'autres dans la région
les antinucléaires venus de france mais
aussi d'europe s'était donné rendez vous
aujourd'hui à strasbourg et pour secouer
les esprits de se sont couchés au sol
pendant quelques minutes simulant
l'hécatombe d'un accident ou d'une
catastrophe nucléaire christophe medard
ces sites huilé
une chaîne humaine autour des
institutions européennes l'image a
valeur de symbole pour ces milliers de
manifestants qui se battent pour une
europe sans nucléaire et qui nous visons
la sortie du nucléaire mais entendu dans
un premier temps il faut empêcher la
construction de nouvelles centrales
et c'est malheureusement le projet du
président de la république le nucléaire
n'est viable ni écologiquement bien sûr
c'est très dangereux ni économiquement
ta coup de fraîcheur ni socialement ça
fait qu'à pôle emploi seule solution
pour les antinucléaires favoriser le
développement des énergies renouvelables
dans le cortège beaucoup de délégations
étrangères venues de toute l'europe avec
en pointe les allemands qui ont décidé
en 2001 d'abandonner progressivement le
nucléaire
nous espérons que l'allemagne sert
d'exemple aux autres pays européens
ça ne sera pas facile mais si nous
sommes unis l'europe pourra sortir du
nucléaire car de grands dangers pour les
manifestants c'est qu'il y ait d'autres
tchernobyl une catastrophe nucléaire qui
a fait de nombreuses victimes auxquelles
on a rendu hommage à travers cette mise
en scène le projet était diabolique tout
comme sa réalisation un vieil homme en
belgique a entièrement piégé sa maison
probablement pour tuer ses 14 enfants et
dans les morts victimes de ces
mécanismes mortel si parfaitement
dissimulé qu'il a fini par les oublier
et par martinez c'est dans cette maison
près de charleroi le 6 octobre que louis
des ti 79 ans est retrouvé mort une
balle lui a transpercé la carotide pour
les policiers belges c'est le début
d'une enquête peu commune le coup de feu
qui a tué le septuagénaire a été tiré
depuis une cage dans un mur un piège
mise au point par la victime elle-même
en fouillant le reste du domicile une
autre balle frôle les enquêteurs en fait
c'est toute la maison qui est truffé de
mécanismes meurtrier tous les pièges
sont très très bien des cheminées donc
tous et replace former un tapis chez on
ne voit rien donc on doit avancer très
méthodiquement et très prudemment ouvrir
la porte du garage le tiroir d'un meuble
ou déplacer un simple casiers de bière
autant de gestes anodins qui aurait dû
tuer partout des pièces sophistiquées
actionnait des armes à feu seule
explication avancée par la police belge
le vieil homme nourrissait une haine
farouche à l'égard de ses 14 enfants
il ne les revoyait plus depuis quinze
ans pour une querelle d'héritage l'a
voulu piéger la maison je pense que
c'était pour nous mais c'est lui qui en
a fait les frais le vieillard a bien
laissé une liste de vingt piège avec une
énigme pour retrouver chacun d'entre eux
les démineurs ont désamorcé 19 mécanisme
pour neutraliser le 20e il leur faudra
résoudre cette devinette les douze
apôtres sont sur le galet nouvel
accident de la route dans les
départements de l'eure trois personnes
ont été tuées et deux autres blessées
dont l'une grièvement apparemment
l'accident qui s'est produit à l'aube
aurait été provoqué par le conducteur
qui s'est assoupi à l'occasion de la
semaine de la sécurité routière un
nouvel examen du permis de conduire va
être très prochainement mise en place
son objectif reculer davantage de
candidats et c'est à l'oral c'est à dire
au moment de la conduite qu'il faudra
être performant dans des domaines
jusqu'ici sous représentés voire ignoré
répondent par exemple sans hésiter à la
localisation du liquide de
refroidissement ou du témoin d'huile
album est aussi philippe guy roux le 16
septembre dernier jacques chirac avait
demandé au gouvernement d initiatives
marquantes en matière de sécurité
routière
un mois plus tard une certitude
l'épreuve du permis de conduire sera
bientôt plus sélectives et voici comment
angers ir après midi à l'arrière de
cette voiture françois millions dans
quinze jours il sera l'un des premiers
inspecteurs à appliquer la réforme
modification la plus spectaculaire la
durée de l'examen passe de 22 à 35
minutes plus de temps et de nouvelles
manoeuvres potentiel exemple l'arrêt de
précisions le candidat doit stopper son
véhicule en face d'un repère précis 25
minutes de conduite de manoeuvre est une
grande nouveauté la connaissance du
véhicule l'inspecteur a amené à demander
où se trouve l'emplacement du liquide de
refroidissement
bon alors je regarde je regarde voilà
c'est bien et puis une question associés
quelles précautions prendre pour
vérifier pour enrober il sera pas
nécessaire d'être ingénieur en mécanique
pour pouvoir passer son permis de
conduire des connaissances élémentaires
que tout un chacun doit avoir pour
conduire dans simplement être vérifiée
cette épreuve
l'objectif général du projet de faire en
sorte que la formation des jeunes
conducteurs soient plus complète le plan
national de formation qui a été
instaurée en 1989 ne pouvait pas être
enseignée dans sa totalité dans une
formation d'une vingtaine d'heure
puisque le minimum obligatoire en france
est de 20 heures une formation allongée
que réclament les auto écoles mais dont
le coût pourrait décourager certains
candidats dans un premier temps le 4
novembre deux départements
l'ille-et-vilaine et le maine-et-loire
expérimenteront le nouvel examen
les pouvoirs publics seront très
attentifs aux résultats le taux de
réussite national est actuellement de 60
%
il pourrait baisser de manière très
sensible en politique française l'udf
autour de françois bayrou tenait son
conseil national le parti centriste qui
a perdu le gros de ses troupes avec la
création de l'ump veut être un acteur
incontournable de la vie politique
un acteur libre dans la majorité à
l'accent de kara leur numéro
tous les hommes politiques
avec l'humour de santini
62 ans pour andré santini un clip vidéo
concoctée par ses amis un peu la
séquence émotion de la convention
nationale de l'udf
un anniversaire mais aussi une
renaissance pour l'udf après la cure
d'amaigrissement de l'été le ralliement
d'une partie des siens l'ump françois
bayrou veut reconstruire son parti avec
une ambition devenir le deuxième pôle de
la majorité qui ont tous les pouvoirs et
qui voudraient de surcroît le monopole
de l'expression se trompe si l'on
choisit l'intérêt national et l'intérêt
de la réforme alors il faut qu'il y ait
dans la majorité
un parti qui soit libre à l'avenir la
liberté certes mais pour quoi faire
il faut d'abord trouver un sens à
l'existence de l'udf au côté de l'ump
pour l'heure le mot d'ordre et combattre
la pensée unique et garder une distance
critique mais tout en douceur les tic
peuvent être positives elle accrédite
positif c'est tout simplement cette
valeur ajoutée qu'on peut apporter une
famille politique on est toujours plus
intelligent à plusieurs que tout seul
mais pour repartir où l'udf doivent
d'abord se réorganiser d'ici janvier
date du prochain congrès les centristes
devront démontrer qu'ils peuvent encore
exister dans le paysage politique
français philippe douste-blazy
secrétaire général de l'ump s'est dit
favorable au droit de vote des immigrés
aux élections locales sous certaines
conditions
c'est déjà un député du même parti qui
s'était prononcé il ya quelques jours
pour le droit de vote des étrangers
philippe douste blazy nous explique ce
pacte l'intégration de nous l'écoutons
chez nos confrères de radio chez il faut
qu'à un moment donné on puisse faire je
dirais une sorte de 2,2 oui deux pacsées
ou de deux programmes d'intégration dans
ce pays dans lequel il y aura un effet
le droit de vote des immigrés qui vit
depuis plus de 10 ans dans une vision
intégrée et qui paie des impôts ça c'est
l'échéance il faudra lui constitue
établir ce pacte mais maintenant à un
mois de la création de l'ump alain juppé
arrivera-t-il à changer son image de
marque cette question apparemment
anodine a pourtant une véritable
importance politique puisque jacques
chirac lui même l'y encouragent et alain
juppé reconnaît qu'il a du travail pour
se rendre
accessible plus sympathique pour briguer
les plus hautes responsabilités c'est
peut-être la raison de sa participation
à l'émission aujourd'hui de michel
drucker chez feet under
c'est lui même qui révélait tout à
l'heure sur france 2 le conseil donné
par jacques siens comment il voyait les
choses et il m'a dit votre programme de
travail c'est très simple souriez
changer son image à paraître plus
souriant moins cassant - point cessé
selon les commentaires alain juppé
assume cette réputation quasiment depuis
ses débuts à ce qu'on croit souvent les
lambent et son agent du sud sud ouest ne
sont pas des gens de peu expansif parce
qu ils sont 25 longiligne une sécheresse
longtemps symbolisé par cette phrase
prononcé lorsqu'il était premier
ministre confronté à des difficultés que
reste droit dans mes bottes et j'aurai
mon travail alors alain juppé at il
changé
certes il semble sourire davantage comme
jacques chirac ne lui a donc demandé
il sourit même d'ailleurs lorsqu'il est
à l'aise on répondait pas aux questions
des journalistes
bref pour ceux qui le connaissent bien
il ya encore un peu de travail
il sait très bien où se
c'est à dire qu'il est il n'est pas
encore achevée puisqu'il a un grand plan
mais de temps en tout les donnent des
coups de griffes mais il est encore
fragile
en tout cas ses proches la firme a
bordeaux c'est un autre juppé 3 il est
temps d'être sympathique et c'est là
même qu'ils aimeraient retrouver sur la
scène nationale car aujourd'hui
l'ancien premier ministre doit retrouver
une popularité que nicolas sarkozy lui
dispute auprès de l'électorat de droite
en ligne de mire la présidentielle alain
juppé s'est aussi qu'une convocation
judiciaire dans les affaires de la
mairie de paris pèse toujours sur lui
bref mieux vaut temps soit je m'en fais
tellement taille et que le groupe
vivendi universal se dit prêt à vendre
son pôle édition et c'est demain que
s'achèvera le dépôt des candidatures
derrière ce sujet purement économique
vivendi ayant besoin d'argent frais pour
éponger ses dettes il ya l'avenir d'une
partie de l'édition française celle de
la rousse notamment mais aussi d'autres
éditeurs qui constituent la richesse de
notre culture
vincent fourcade martin wyss le petit
larousse illustré une de nos meilleures
ventes
propriété de vue vue pour vivendi
universal publishing le numéro 1
français de l'édition au catalogue
impressionnant
les dictionnaires larousse et robert
s'est vu tout comme la plupart des
éditions scolaires ou universitaires
plomb la faune julliard et autres c'est
encore vu et le tout est à vendre pour
environ 3 milliards d'euros car vivendi
a des dettes des créanciers de plus en
plus nerveux et donc un besoin urgent
d'argent frais des pans entiers du
patrimoine culturel national cherche
maintenant preneur et chez les libraires
l'inquiétude monte
si on voit le larousse partir à
l'étranger on dira quand même c'est
dommage larousse un pur produit français
qu'on aimerait bien garder chez nous
deux fois en investissement
franco-américain sont d'ailleurs dans la
course au rachat
l'édition ce n'est pas vraiment leur
métier d'où la crainte des salariés du
pôle édition de vivendi qu'à terme une
logique purement financière ne balaie
tout sur son passage
l'édition et le livre c'est ça c'est une
vraie question de fond est ce que c'est
simplement une marchandise comme une
autre et qu'on peut la vendre au même
titre je dirais qu'une boîte de petits
points ou est-ce qu'elle a une dimension
autre troisième candidat le groupe
lagardère qui joue la carte de la
défense de la culture française problème
à travers achète il est déjà numéro deux
du secteur avec vue proche il
deviendrait incontournable beaucoup trop
au goût des indépendants comme gallimard
qui craignent pour la diversité de
l'offre littéraire passerelle désolant
qu'il se passe ce qui s'est passé pour
la musique où il ya deux trois majeurs
musique deux grandes chaînes disquaires
rien d'autre le nom du repreneur sera
connu à la fin du mois mais un point et
déjà acquis quelle que soit l'option
choisie par le patron de vivendi
elle ne fera pas que des heureux jacques
chirac était à damas aujourd'hui
rencontrant bachar al assad la question
de la crise irakienne de l'avenir du
proche orient était bien sûr au coeur de
ces discussions le chef de l'état
français qui a poursuivi sa tournée en
arrivant en fin de journée à man
il est en ce moment même au palais pour
un entretien avec le roi abdallah en
irak geste politique sans précédent à un
geste de clémence jamais vu saddam
hussein a décidé de gracier tous les
détenus y compris les prisonniers
politiques
la grâce est totale globale et
définitive et on imagine la stupeur et
la satisfaction des prisonniers lorsque
les portes se sont ouvertes envoyés
spéciaux maryse burgot jean françois
renaud au milieu d'une foule compacte
les détenus libérés ont bien du mal à
quitter la prison hier soir encore les
hommes ne savais pas qu aujourd'hui il
se remet à la nouvelle s'est répandue
dans la ville comme une traînée de
poudre l'annoncent ce matin de l'amener
ici général a attiré une foule immense
devant les portes de cette crise ont à
30 km de bagdad
des familles des détenus demandent aux
premiers prisonniers libérés des
nouvelles de ceux qui ne sont pas encore
sortis plus loin des frères se
retrouvent après des années de
séparation
les prisonniers de droit commun remercie
saddam hussein pour ce geste de clémence
et la foule scande des slogans à la
gloire du président la mli ce qui
concerne tous les prisonniers sauf ceux
qui ont commis des crimes de sang et
ceux qui ont été condamnés pour
espionnage au profit des états unis
les autres tous les autres ce prince de
rentrer chez eux
les gardiens ont déserté leurs miradors
il surveille est ici plusieurs milliers
de prisonniers politiques condamnés
entre autres pour leur appartenance à
une minorité ethnique ou religieuse ce
chiite vient de passer du temps derrière
les barreaux pour avoir eu des liens
avec un parti politique proche de l'iran
sont des professeurs de l'université de
mossoul pour se protéger il préfère
taire les raisons de leur condamnation
plus loin un jeune explique qu'il a
participé à un rite religieux interdit
cette amnistie générale sans précédent
permettent un feu d'amy sène de faire
oublier tout un sens à son peuple les
menaces américaines les prisonniers qui
ont commis des crimes de sang ne seront
libérés que si l'on le pardon des
familles des victimes
saddam hussein demande à ces familles de
limiter et d'accorder elles aussi leur
clémence
en israël l'armée s'est retirée de la
colonie de havât gilad en cisjordanie où
une cinquantaine de personnes ont été
blessées dans des affrontements qui ont
opposé soldats et colons qui refusaient
le démantèlement de leurs installations
illégales leur implantation fait
naplouse provoqué distension sein même
du gouvernement et c'est dès le milieu
de semaine de mise la défense a ordonné
ce démantèlement qui finalement n'a pas
abouti en corse un attentat dans un
village de vacances appartenant au
ministère de l'intérieur près d'ajaccio
deux des trois bâtiments ont été
endommagés pas de blessés pas de
revendication une enquête a été ouverte
une page médecine avec cette affection
virale qui touche essentiellement les
petits la bronchiolite l' angoisse des
parents est depuis ce week end ils ont à
disposition un numéro vert pour
contacter les kinés susceptible de
soulager leur bébé julia delage du des
maurels qu'à lui souffre d'une grosse
viol x pour le soigner une seule méthode
la timidité rapide le luth faire tousser
le nourrisson pour libérer ses voies
respiratoires des gestes impressionnant
mais indispensable à sa guérison
il offre la plus calme et surtout tout
de suite après la séance il va mieux
donc c'est peut-être un mal pour un bien
en france chaque année près de 450 mille
bébés sont touchés par la bronchiolite
et ce chiffre augmente sans cesse depuis
un an les kinésithérapeutes du réseau
bronchiolite soulage les nourrissons
chaque week-end et jours fériés pour
éviter toute aggravation sur une
continuité des soins
enfin disons de ne pas laisser l'enfant
sans soins week-end ou des jours fériés
de façon à optimiser le résultat et puis
des pistes et dans certains cas des
ongles aggravation une disponibilité qui
rassure beaucoup la maman de nolan je
pense en 48 heures s'agit s'aggraver et
serait-elle hospitalisation c'est la
première bronchiolites de nolan et sa
mère sait que ce ne sera sûrement pas la
dernière de l'hiver cette année les
médecins craignent en effet une épidémie
particulièrement virulente
rien qu'aujourd'hui ce qui n'est a reçu
près de 20 nous ils sont malades
un record pour cette période de l'année
l'ouverture du salon international de
l'alimentation cinq mille exposants et
près de 100 pays représentés pour
présenter les nouveautés de l'industrie
alimentaire que nous montre marie-pierre
ces métiers laurent heslault le retour
du rosbif anglais qu'on peut déguster ou
[ __ ] les producteurs de viande
britanniques ont mis les petits plats
dans les grands
ils ont même obtenu une dérogation pour
apporter les 400 kilos de viande bovine
qui lie à ici car l'arrêté officiel qui
lève l'embargo n'a pas encore été publié
bien sûr les étiquettes ont été
particulièrement soignés alors ça vient
de l'abattoir de sainte marine qui se
trouve au pays de galles juste à la
frontière de l'angleterre
et ces animaux sont en fait acheter
autour de l'abattoir dans la région du
sud du pays de galles
côté français on découvre le premier
steaks hachés label rouge lancée par
deux coopératives agricoles sur le
paquet on affiche la traçabilité
objectif rassurer les consommateurs qui
boudent est le steack haché depuis
quelques années un numéro de lot qui
informatiquement correspond à l'origine
des animaux c'est la traçabilité
aujourd'hui qu'on a complètement
développé dans tous les logements neufs
cette année on met l'accent sur
l'authenticité et l'origine des produits
les étiquettes sont très détaillés car
le consommateur devient de plus en plus
curieux tu l'achètes amiel par exemple
comme celui ci il a besoin de savoir
quelle est ta miel d'acacia qui via les
colis du danube on lui raconte d'où
vient produit comment il était comment
ils étaient produits on vient du monde
entier pour visiter cette grande vitrine
de l'industrie alimentaire industrie
alimentaire dont la france tient le
premier rang en europe
une semaine après le décès de la
française audrey maistre qui tentait à
nouveau record de plongée en apnée loïc
leferme a dédié son exploit la
championne disparu c'est dans les eaux
profondes de la rade de
villefranche-sur-mer qu'il a atteint 162
mètres de profondeur égalant le record
mondial
les vétérans frédéric série il déguste
une dernière fois sa bouffée d'air avant
de s'embarquer pour le grand bleu 162
mètres plus bas
loïc leferme pratiquer la plongée nos
limites il descend le plus profond
possible
la plongée à la française c'est un sport
d'équipé
le plongeur et les sauveteurs
s'entraînent ensemble minimiser les
risques avec des plongeurs le 12 octobre
dernier audrey maistre 28 ans a trouvé
la mort en tentant les 171 m syncope en
eaux profondes
il a fallu neuf minutes pour la remontée
à la surface beaucoup trop long
j'espère que ça va faire un électrochoc
pour tous les gens qui dans le monde
parce qu'il ya beaucoup dans le monde
qui font qu'ils pratiquent cette
discipline et qui le font dans des
conditions à ces limites ou qu'ils
réfléchissent pas vraiment sur leur
système de sécurité derniers mètres dans
la nuit enfin la gueuse s'arrête une
minute cinquante deux descentes et un
pincement au coeur pour loïc leferme qui
repense à son amie audrey j'ai pensé en
descendant puis c'était un peu pour elle
que je les fais quoi
oui c'est vrai que c'est assez sympa
rester bizarre mais ce qui est sympa
après c'est la remontée le moment
critique plus d'une minute avant la
surface
enfin le record de pippin le cubain et
égalé et le tout en toute sécurité
4 avec le retour sur scène de gérard
jugnot en costume cette fois-ci et sans
moustache et incarne le critique
littéraire sainte-beuve un homme plutôt
disgracieux et sans talent de créateur
passionné pour la femme de victor hugo à
des lâches dont il appréciait la beauté
et la compagnie et surtout à travers
elle le génie de son mari une pièce
extrêmement réussi très souvent drôle
gérard jugnot est notre invité mais
d'abord dans les coulisses du théâtre
centaines il s'apprête à jouer état
critique se fit jour j -philippe geste
là bonjour c
et elle c'est juliette qui ne l'aiment
pas gérard jugnot avant de revêtir les
habits de sainte-beuve passe en revue
les femmes qui vont le faire souffrir le
réel point fort mais voici annick alan
casque ou maman sainte beuve qui lie
tous et maintenant il est temps de
revêtir les habits du grand homme c'est
un grand homme vraiment ça m'a presque
est bien choisi d'aller gagner à bien
jouer napoléon je me tiens mu masse et
le progrès des risques jouer autre chose
puisque j'ai joué c'est vrai que c'est
un artiste moyens mais de petits gerra
moyens sainte beuve
il y aura eu toute une palette de rôles
de plus en plus complexes où l'émotion
fini par l'emporter
des hommes ordinaires au destin
extraordinaire un portrait qu'il décline
de film en film
ce portrait jugnot l'enrichît encore en
abordant pour la première fois un
personnage historique fini c'est fini
et quand tu n'as rien s'il vous plaît
vite restant sa revente a chuté avec
peut-être encore un petit doute sur sa
crédibilité d'acteurs de théâtre
je ne sais pas parler mais je suis
franchement là je suis déçu quand on a
la chance de pouvoir quelqu'un qui peut
à la fois à lier cette humanité là et
donc une émotion qui va avec et son sens
du rire et du comique qui là bas c'est
un cadeau formidable et sur des rôles
comme ça qui sont les rôles ambigus et
qui mélange les deux basses et des
personnages idéaux pour le faire rassuré
grand gérard est d'avoir le même succès
au théâtre qu'au cinéma
tous les soirs je suis entière fontaine
dans un état critique je me consume
on sort alors avant de vous consume et
totalement par un temps long de la pièce
une pièce où on rit aux éclats arrière
qui est parfois grinçant à rire franc à
rire d'émotion
en fait c'est pas vraiment une comédie
ça rien de votre ville qu'est-ce qu'il
faut vous fait rire vous dans cette
pièce de sa veuve
tous essaient des personnages très
douloureux monsieur c'est un personnage
qui qui se bat avec la avec
l'intelligence contre le génie quoi il
ya un tir au dessus et à hugo et lui
sera jamais go comment comme dans dans
la vie a toujours un type comme ça
qu'ils travaillent pas et qui a 18 et
vous avez 12 en travaillant de une brute
donc un personnage comme ça douloureux
et il est douloureux parce qu'en plus il
est amoureux fou de cette femme et il a
6 brûlés quoi et à travers elle bien sûr
de oui il a le talent de reconnaître le
génie de journée d'ailleurs une très
belle tirade sur la justice à la
naissance les bonnes femmes s'en sont
pas partout oyiba les migrants la
justice au est absolument vous avez vous
le sentiment d'avoir fait des plus de
plutôt bonne fébus et le jour je crois
que le talent c'est pas le dont le
talent dans l'être dans la vie
d'ailleurs c'est le lard de développer
ce don et je crois beaucoup à ça je
crois beaucoup au travail je crois
beaucoup au fait que tout le monde a
reçu beaucoup de choses mais que le
petit truc c'est d'arriver à développer
elle est passée à huy on a bossé cette
pièce est très difficile
si seulement vous aimez ses débuts j'ai
dit je les normands appréciez vous dites
d'ailleurs emprunt ce personnage est en
jeu comme si on était à bicyclette ça
veut dire quoi
oui parce que c'est un personnage
tellement il est douloureux parce qu'il
est tout tout tout tout le fait souffrir
c'est ça qui fait rire les gens
d'ailleurs c'est ça qui est atroce ce
que je trouve formidable pièce est une
comédie dramatique sire que tout ce qui
lui arrive est affreux et drôle et est
terrible et en même temps ça fait rire
c'est c'est affreux mais les gens rient
et je suis très surprise de voir comment
ça se passe depuis une semaine
alors vous êtes en costume on l'a dit
est ce que c'est difficile de rentrer
dans la peau de sainte-beuve dans
j'imagine la vie une habitante niveau
jean niveau du jeu sans plus
win le ccsa de bugs mais l'histoire
c'est l'histoire de ce petit bonhomme
qui est sans gras sansa qui se
retrouvent l'est qui va se battre et qui
va être perçue quitté par toutes ces
femmes vous avez tous plus ou moins de
le voir vous l'aviez déjà fait oui
c'était comment de rentrer dans
justement de danse et ses costumes
historiques
on vous imagine r très bien du molière
ou oui lorsqu'il sort bien c'est que la
pièce qui est écrite par michel
lengliney qui est une pièce
contemporaine elle est moderne elle
parle avec un très beau langage mois que
j'aime beaucoup et ça ça a été très
difficile de rendre facile léger et
drôle et comme un courant 7
cette très belle langue mais bon si le
costume cède alors amo quand même d'hugo
parce que hugo est absent de la pièce on
en parle tout seul et c'est un monstre
hugo je vous dois parler alors on ne
parle que deux choses son talent et puis
sa virilité démesurée oui c'est un titre
très puissants pendant la nuit de noce
je crois qu'il a honoré une fois sa
femme cette approche la piste historique
qu'est ce que vous avez envie qu'on n'en
retienne vous avez envie d'entendre quoi
quand on sort c'est moi ce que j'adore
dans la pièce en ce moment soit le
massage peut on parler le soft pourrait
pas parler de ce qu'il n'existait pas
c'est que les gens viennent pour rire
souvent iri et puis un soulier dessinant
ce formidable et ça j'aime beaucoup ça
veut dire que les silences les émotions
puis on a eu des très beaux
applaudissements c'est agréable c'est
mieux qu'un coup de pied au cul on a eu
une standing-ovation mais debout c'est
la fin de ce journal dans quelques
instants la météo de nathalie rihouet
20h50 votre série urgences ce minuit dix
derniers jours un journal lance ticket
de matchs dès 6h30 télématin dans les 4
vérités françoise laborde recevra
françois hollande premier secrétaire du
ps 13 heures d'élise bilalian 20h david
pujadas demain soir vous croisez arlette
chabot rapport terme entre autres
l'insécurité comme
moi je vous remercie de votre attention
on se quitte sur ces images de l'île
d'hawaï où se déroulait aujourd'hui le
championnat du monde de triathlon 1600
participants pour trois épreuves le 3 km
de nage 180 km de course cycliste et
pour finir pour finir les 42 kilomètres
du marathon